and in the past 24 hours no deaths have
been registered of patients confirmed
through a test as having covered 19 the
total number of deaths in Scotland under
that measurement therefore remains at
2415 now this is of course the second
day in a row that no deaths have been
registered in the preceding 24 hours
this is obviously very encouraging I
can't tell you how much I've longed to
report such a development and I know all
of you will have longed to hear that but
even so we must still exercise caution
we know from previous weeks that fewer
deaths tend to be registered at weekends
so it's still highly likely that more
Cova deaths will be recorded in the days
ahead but I very much hope that we will
continue to see a steady decline as
always of course I want to stress that
the figures I have been reporting over
the past few weeks are not just
statistics the represent individuals
whose loss is a source of sorrow to many
my deepest condolences are with everyone
who has lost a loved one to this virus
and I also want to express again my
thanks to our health and care workers
for the incredible work that you
continue to do in very testing
circumstances